how is that not leading the news one of
the jurors reportedly sported a t-shirt
that says blm
apparently he also ran a podcast
covering george floyd and other racial
justice issues
well it leaves you with a pretty strong
case for a mistrial
okay so this leads to certain
predictable effects when you castigate
the cops as racist when you suggest that
the cops
are big danger to americans there's a
video that i think is kind of important
because
we very rarely talk about the behavior
of people when they interact with police
officers
you know we hear very often that if
you're black in america you have to
teach your kids keep your hands at 10
and 2 on the wheel
treat the officer with respect first of
all you should teach your kids to do
that regardless of your color
because the cop is armed and you
presumably are not the cop is an officer
of law and you presumably are not
and you should be treating police
officers with respect that is a simple
thing to do
but put that aside for a second when you
incentivize people to treat cops badly
that is not a good idea and it does lead
to worse behaviors so for example here
is a california woman
who was pulled over for she had her cell
phone up on it which is a violation in
california you're not allowed to have
your cell phones your ear in california
i know because i used to live there she
was pulled over and uh this exchange
just says pretty much everything about
how it is seen fit to treat police
officers in america right now
why are you harassing me you're correct
i pulled you over because you're a
murderer
yes i started to record because you
can't be it you can't be on your cell
phone while you're driving
when i was recording you can you call
your supervisor please
i already did he's on his way because
you're a murderer okay
do you have you had that pictured me and
made me think you were gonna murder me
okay well i'm sorry you feel that way
well you're that's not just a feeling
you're a murderer
okay thank you and i'm perfectly legal
and i'm a teacher so there
congratulations
you're a murderer okay now quick thing
here
one typically a thing that you cannot
say to murderers and get away with being
alive is is you are a murderer right
things that people never said to charles
manson
right hey i'm sorry that's such an
absurd
i'm a teacher it's a flag okay but
that sort of behavior is now being
intensified like this lady thought for
sure
she was gonna go viral right that's why
she's taping it she thinks she's gonna
put that up on tick tock and she's gonna
go viral
look at how i spoke back to this
murdering pig officer okay that sort of
attitude is not going to
either get you anywhere in life or going
to incentivize the kind of behaviors
that lead to a lowering of crime i think
police officers want to be treated this
way
you think police officers want to get
into situations and there's a pretty
mild situation the lady's not actually
physically resisting arrest for example
but to believe that that doesn't happen
is to ignore the evidence on the ground
okay and and this has now infused so
much of our conversation
right the anti-police anti-american
rhetoric has infused so much
of our conversation that we're supposed
to ignore relevant stories
in favor of irrelevant stories we're
supposed to pay attention
to this lady's feeling about this cop
we're supposed to pay attention to
police officers doing the right thing
and shooting people who are threatening
other people but we're not supposed to
pay attention
to actual active active apparent malice
okay so this brings us to what in any in
any normal situation would lead the news
right this story would lead the news
here is the story and it has not
appeared so far somewhere on any network
news show
i believe it has not been covered at cnn
it's an unbelievable story
okay so the most glorified criminal
justice trial
since rodney king was the derek chauvin
trial was the number one trial covered
in america
the derek chauvin situation spawned
riots and protests the protest involved
somewhere between 15 and 26 million
americans
according to studies and then
a couple weeks ago derek chovan was
convicted on all accounts and i said at
the time
i think you could get to manslaughter
maybe i think i find it very difficult
to believe that a jury could get to
second and third degree murder
after 10 hours of consideration with no
questions asked of the judge
i just thought it is very hard for me to
believe that you get there without any
preconceived notions after three weeks
of testimony you come in
with a conviction on all accounts second
third degree murder and manslaughter
on the basis of the evidence that was
provided without asking any questions
right in 10 hours i said i found that
very difficult to believe
and people were very upset with that how
could you say that this is how the
criminal justice system works which i
pointed out well if it had come out the
other way in 10 hours you'd have said
that it was biased that way so
obviously you just don't like the
outcome what i'm saying is if they'd
considered this for a week and then
they'd come back with that verdict
i still would have thought they got it
wrong but at least i would have thought
they considered the evidence
you come back in 10 hours after a three
week trial on something like that
and it doesn't seem to me that the jury
did a great job considering the evidence
just on the basis of the sort of outside
on the basis of the the outside data
well now we know
now we know that at least one of these
jurors
was apparently an activist according to
daily wire
one of the jurors who served on the
murder trial of former minneapolis
police officer derek chovan
reportedly sported a black lives matter
t-shirt with a reference to the death of
george floyd
seemingly challenging what the juror
told the chauvin defense team during
jury selection
according to a report from the
post-millennial now public juror brandon
mitchell 31
is seen in a facebook post published in
august 2020
right well before the trial august 2020
wearing a hat
that says black lives matter and a
t-shirt that says blm
with the words get your knee off our
necks a reference to the death of floyd
the photo was posted by a travis
mitchell with the caption the next
generation being socially active
representing in dc
my son marzell my nephew brandon rene
mitchell and brother maurice johnson
johnson here's the photo and question
was tweeted out by jack bosobiac
also this person apparently runs a
podcast
mitchell told the judge on march 15th
when he was asked if he was aware of the
shoving case
and george floyd he said quote he'd
heard some basic info about trial dates
etc from the news
but not the sort of information that
would keep him from serving as an
impartial juror
apparently he also ran a podcast
covering george floyd and other racial
justice issues
he then went on to give an interview to
the wall street journal in which he
described how he decided to go public to
help
push for change and told of his many
negative experiences dealing with law
enforcement when he was younger
if mitchell was truly unfamiliar with
the george floyd case before joining the
jury he certainly made up for lost time
in a hurry says hot air
but that seems patently preposterous so
where exactly
does that leave us now well it leaves
you with a pretty
strong case for a mistrial i mean
this if this guy is the juror which
apparently he is
how is that not leading the news i mean
i i honestly don't understand how does
that not lead the news let's say that
derek shoven had been
acquitted and it turns out one of the
jurors had been wearing a blue lives
matter t-shirt with a shirt that said
derek chovin is innocent
do you think that that might be the
cause of some consternation
but there have you seen the story
covered anywhere anywhere
because again the narrative must be
pursued at the cost of the fact at the
cost of individual justice
if need if need be pretty astonishing
stuff
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
so you stay up to date with all our
future content